Attorney General Jeff session says the
New York City police officer killed by a
gunman was targeted and murdered in a
cowardly unprovoked attacked officer
Minnesota's Familia was shot in the head
early yesterday morning the 48 year-old
mother of three died just hours later at
a Bronx Hospital
the gunman 34 year old Alexander bonds
was killed by police Don Dahler is
outside the officers precinct in the
Bronx with what's being done to protect
police Don good morning good morning
after three of its officers were killed
sitting in their vehicles the NYPD began
retrofitting patrol cars with
bulletproof windows and ballistic panels
but it's unclear if the mobile command
vehicle that officer familia was sitting
in was ever intended to have those
protective upgrades New York City police
officers overcome with grief joined
hands on Wednesday outside Mia sotas
familias police precinct hours earlier
the 12 year NYPD veteran was shot in the
head the bullet shattering the window of
the Marc command vehicle she was sitting
in this is unnecessary took the life of
a person that was such a beautiful
person without even knowing that she was
such a beautiful person it's senseless
it doesn't make any sense responding
officers shot and killed Alexander bonds
about a block from the crime scene they
recovered this revolver allegedly stolen
in West Virginia detectives searched
bonds Bronx apartment for a motive
polices and they say no gimme on his
Facebook page bonds often ranted against
police don't think every brother cousin
uncle you got that get killed in jails
because of a blood or [ __ ] Lang T
killing Nam police be chilling he's
saying it and make children bonds
girlfriend reportedly called 911 Tuesday
night to tell police that he was acting
irrational and erratic and in a manic
depressed state bonds apparently
suffered from schizophrenia and had been
taking antipsychotic medication in a
letter to New York City Police
Commissioner James O'Neill says familia
was assassinated and murdered for her
uniform it is clear this was an
unprovoked attack
on police officers who are assigned to
keep the people at his great city safe
bonds had been arrested six previous
times including for attacking a police
officer with brass knuckles in 2001 at
the time of the shooting he was out on
parole for robbery Gail it's tough to
hear thank you very much Don Dahler